[Applause]
[Applause]
well he needs no introduction but we're
going to give him one anyway he is the
number one selling solo artist
in us history ladies and gentlemen garth
brooks
the one and only garth good morning
we're so happy to have you on the show
i'm so excited you're just going to show
two sides of the spectrum there in notre
dame it was
freezing cold
[Laughter]
garth we have been waiting and waiting
for your show at allegiant stadium
of course it's gotten pushed back so
many times finally happening though next
month what can we expect uh you can just
expect a lot of uh
just a lot of chaos at high volume
pretty much
you know you're going to go in there
with all these plans and they're going
to go out the window the first five
seconds because it's the first show back
so
it's just going to be full of mistakes
and it's going to be it's going to be a
total train wreck but it's going to be a
lot of fun
well we we like the idea of it being a
train wreck we all have a good time
there you know it's been pushed back i
think it was just going to
august i think was the initial date uh
opening up at a legion stadium
hopefully it's given some more time to
add some more train wreckable things to
the show we're looking forward to it
and also more seats going on sale for
the show garth which is fantastic
um what do you love about coming to las
vegas uh
what i love about it is it's it's since
everybody kind of comes there
and the people that already live there
are really just full of common sense
you get this total full spectrum of
everything when you get in place so if
you did the one-man show there at wind
when we were there if you go back to the
t-mobile or the thomas mack
all those places it's always been a
great experience and
the greatest compliment you can give to
any city is
why are you coming back we're coming
back because we've been there and we
cannot wait
hey garth congrats on your honor from
the kennedy center uh i heard you
talking about it you said you had never
been
in a crowd for friends in low places now
you know what we feel like what was it
like for you
it was great it was a lot more work than
i'm used to because i don't have a thing
so but it was it was fun to get to stand
up and and clap and sing
i thought jimmy allen did a great job
with it and then come on
you kidding me james taylor gladys
knight kelly clarkson that was uh that
was um
the square sky in the room got to feel
like the coolest guy in the room
yeah the performances for that were
fantastic especially also at the
inauguration
that was another fantastic performance
in dc as well garth let's talk we have
to talk about the pandemic unfortunately
and
covet obviously you uh your wife was
affected tricia
and it's delayed your show what has it
been like for an
artist like yourself to push through
this to deal with the shows being
canceled to try and find ways to
entertain
while still being stuck at home yeah
well man know that uh you're being stuck
with the love of your life which is
great
of course well that was good news and
and as far as us going through anything
we went through nothing compared to what
everybody else
went through with this thing but i think
what we all saw is what we don't want to
see again
if that makes any sense so our job being
one of the first entertainers back in
full capacity
our job is to be responsible our job is
to make sure those people that come to a
legion stadium
leave there with only one mission in
minor one goal or one worry in mind
that's loving each other more than when
they came not anything about safety
stadiums got that state rules have got
that
so you take care of those people that
take care of you and
so hopefully people come there with no
worries if somebody's wearing a mask
don't look at them strange if somebody's
not wearing a mask don't look at them
strange
we're all there to love one another and
then sing you can sing right through
those masks as well as you can with them
out
yes just focus on the train wreck and
then you're good to go
garth that's why we love you we can't
wait to welcome you back to las vegas
thank you so much for joining us
and happy father's day to you you have a
good weekend getting back to you guys i
love you all